ces agressions évidemment choc et une
terreur sur notamment la question de la
sécurité dans les établissements
scolaires y at il de plus en plus de
violence à l'école comment remédier à ce
phénomène qui sont grandissants faut-il
sécuriser les lycées c'est l'objet de
notre face à face
est avec nous pour en parler jean pierre
lecoq maire dû 6e arrondissement de
paris justement que se trouve le lycée
montaigne où s'est produit cette
agression bonsoir monsieur lecoq merci
infiniment d'être avec nous en direct
sur les france sur ce plateau également
les ondes de fontaine porte parole de
fabien roussel le candidat du parti
communiste à la présidentielle vous est
aussi secrétaire général des jeunes
communistes qui représente 60% aussi des
des étudiants tout d'abord un jean
pierre lecoq puisque vous êtes le maire
du 6e arrondissement je le disais est ce
que vous avez des nouvelles de cette
professeur qui a été hospitalisé hier
qui semble être sortie est ce qu'elle va
mieux à l'heure qu'il est quel est son
état d'esprit et surtout son état de
santé dans les
[Musique]
clous devrait être son et je souhaite
qu'elle soit moins choqué possible par
cette agression injustifiable j'ajoute
d'ailleurs que je n'ai jamais été
contacté par le rectorat ou pas
l'intéressé quai des mines il appert il
ya soit parce que le commissaire de
police du vième combat qui m'a informé
de cet incident majeur et de la tranchée
de fait que le jeune lycéen était
entendue dans les locaux de la police
j'ai eu ensuite un contact avec le
proviseur qui m'a kim a également
informé de effet mais je sais simplement
les par la
tâche qui est une cellule psychologique
psychologique de monter qu'une assemblée
générale bien justifier les professeurs
s'est rassemblée et que votre reportage
l'a montré l'émoi est bien sûr plus que
palpable j'ai glissé
on entendait justement des lycéens de
dire voilà le lycée montaigne jamais de
la vie on voit ça est ce que c'est le
cas où est-ce que vous en tant que maire
vous avez une vision sur évidemment
plusieurs établissements de votre
arrondissement j'imagine est ce que
c'est un phénomène que vous pouvez
constater ici ou là des violences au
sein de l'école pas forcément contre les
professeurs mais aussi contre les élèves
ou les élèves rentrent au
wifi ou pas il faut il pas là fait
particulier en déduire des loges et les
conséquences des conséquences générales
notamment sur le segment des centres
installant très favorisés avec des
lycées prestigieux lycée fénelon le la
cité sphères où tu ailles le lycée
saint-louis aussi
énormément d'établissements privés
participant au service public de
l'éducation nationale où après six bouts
les choix cueilli cloutier
à 52 fait bon c'est le dit en général de
l'autorité dans ce pays un peu le roi
tous les lots dans l'enseignement au
niveau sociétal du mythique exemple le
refus de l'autorité en général et puis
il faut aussi se rend compte que le nous
sortons de la crise sanitaire qui était
une crise sanitaire est accompagné de
beaucoup de privation de liberté ça a pu
aussi avoir des conséquences sapeurs les
conséquences sur chacun d'entre nous sur
les plus faibles d'entre eux moussa peut
avoir sa plus conduire à des
comportements qui sont bien sûr qu'ils
ne sont pas qui ne sont pas justifiables
mais qui peuvent être compréhensibles
alors les ondes de fontaine c'est vrai
qu'un on a une idée de ce petit débat
parce qu'effectivement il ya aussi
roubaix où les professeurs sont en grève
c'est pas rien quand même l'introduction
d'armes à feu dans l'enceinte de
l'établissement des gaz lacrymo tout ça
en une journée c'est vrai qu'on voit
souvent malheureusement de l'actualité
des faits de violence dans les écoles
que ce soit contre les élèves vous
comptez professeur est ce que c'est un
phénomène selon vous qui tend à cette
pâte
c'est un phénomène qui n'est pas nouveau
mais en effet qui tend à s'accroître on
voit les témoignages et de tels actes
horribles se multiplier partout
d'ailleurs je tiens aussi à transmettre
toute ma solidarité à la fois la victime
et à l'ensemble du corps enseignant que
ça a profondément choqué
maintenant ça fait une dizaine d'années
qu'on commence à en parler de ces actes
de violence au sein des écoles des
lycées et des collèges et ça fait une
dizaine d'années que les réponses
politiques restent les mêmes c'est il
faut davantage de sécurité davantage
d'autorité voilà et ça fait 10 ans et
pourtant en effet les phénomènes se
multiplient à travers le territoire et
évitement d'autorité comme dit monsieur
le maire à l'image peut-être dû du pays
je sais pas si c'est à l'image du pays
parce que viadeo débats face à ces
différents mais la réalité c'est que sur
l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui il ya
un problème c'est que les enseignants
travaillent dans des conditions de plus
en plus catastrophique et source à aucun
candidat n'a importe de revendication de
propositions au clair là dessus si ce
n'est fabien roussel qui propose lui le
recrutement de 90 mille enseignants et
concrètement ça veut dire dédoubler les
classes passer à 25 élèves par classe et
ça c'est un enjeu notamment pour
permettre aux enseignants de mieux gérer
leurs classes de mieux tenir leur classe
parce qu'aujourd'hui en fait quand on a
quarante élèves fassent 40 élèves en
face de nous eh bien oui c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui de pouvoir enseigner dans de
bonnes conditions c'est un enjeu de
société de pouvoir offrir à la fois les
meilleures conditions de travail pour
nos enseignants et les meilleures
conditions de formation pour pour nos
jeunes et ça c'est une ambition qu'on se
donne jean pierre lecoq vous
vous diriez il faut davantage peut-être
sécurisé on imagine que vous allez être
invité à des à des réunions sur ce thème
en tant que maire après cet incident au
lycée montaigne on parle beaucoup des
portillons à l'entrée des lycées
on va pas citer la sphère samuel pâtit
qui a peut-être rien à voir dans fin
quand même eu mort d'homme dont les
sandales d'un établissement quasiment
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut sécuriser
davantage clairement les établissements
scolaires je crois qu'il faut plutôt mis
là il ya des situations différentes
différent même si elles concourent tous
effectivement elle participe tous un
climat de violence ont samuel bâtisse et
bien sûr la chose la plus horrible
puisse arriver mais dans le cadre d'une
personne qui était totalement a dit
alizé à la simple pose le problème de la
l'identification des personnes
radicalisait
deuxièmement
celui ce qui s'est passé à roubaix donc
l'intrusion d'une arme à feu donc là
effectivement c'est une des armes à feu
c'est le problème du funk soul en
circulation en vente libre et puis et
puis mon tel c'est un autre niveau
viendrait bien que de toute façon un
portillon
d'être servis robben n'aurait aucune
utilité avantage est-ce que c'est nos
comportements violents
réagissant à nova et la professeur qui
lui a été rendu à passer à l'acte c'est
à dire agressé ses professeurs ont aussi
aimé il y apparaît les informations que
vous le savez dire que billy timmons et
élèves que je ne veux pas ostraciser
mais d'un élève qui avait des
antécédents qui va et violentes
auxquelles nous unit difficulté c'est la
question de la du fait canal est violent
et souvent x pull d'établissement mais
qu'il
sent d'ailleurs que quelquefois les
autorités la direction de ce lycée
soient clairement informés donc ça
proposant même de traçabilité de 2,2
d'identification sans ostracisation
puisque chacun sait que l'être humain
peut capable de réservation c'est à dire
à une période difficile il peut succéder
les périodes je dirais
d'amélioration mais pour les plus pour
les élèves les plus difficiles il faut
se poser la question
d'établissements spécialisés qui avait
d'ailleurs créé sous nicolas sarkozy qui
a été a été fermée ou
abandonnés par enfant françois hollande
et qui n'ont pas été rétablies c'est
difficile c'est une toute petite
minorité mais il faut peut-être les
prélever parce qu'on peut pas les
laisser à céret d'un mc dans des
collèges classiques on va écouter
quelques réactions un politique puisque
cette affaire a tout de même fait réagir
ce matin aussi bien à droite qu'à gauche
qui coûtait
au lycée montaigne agression d'une
grande violence d'une professeur par un
élève de 15 ans en plein cours soutien
total et chaleureuses pensées à cette
enseignante face à la montée des
violences l'institution scolaire doit
réagir vigoureusement tout mon soutien à
la professeur du lycée montaigne victime
d'une violente agression d'un élève je
condamne fermement cette violence et
cette dégradation du climat scolaire mon
soutien et ma sympathie à la professeure
de mathématiques agressé par un élève de
seconde au lycée montaigne la violence
n'est tolérable nulle part encore moins
nos établissements scolaires foyer du
savoir de la tolérance et de
l'apprentissage à la vie sociale on
entend à l'institution scolaire doit
notamment réagir c'est ce que dit
valérie pécresse
l'institution scolaire est ce qu'elle a
son rôle à jouer ce que ce sont les
parents comme le dit monsieur le maire
il faudrait peut-être réfléchir à
d'autres solutions notamment sous
sarkozy avoir des lieux spécialisés pour
accueillir certains élèves et alors
l'éducation nationale et je dirais
j'irai même plus loin et la solution
pour répondre à ces violences comment se
fait-il qu'aujourd'hui des jeunes qui
sont dans ce système scolaire ou qui
sont issues de systèmes scolaires en
arrive à de tels actes moi je pense que
il faut regarder aujourd'hui ce que nous
disent les premiers concernés les élèves
les enseignants les parents d'élèves et
il nous dit tous ils nous disent ils
nous disent tous qu'il ya un problème de
moyens écoutons-les travaillons avec eux
et aujourd'hui quand on voit le nombre
d'élèves qui a dans les établissements
vis-à-vis des cpe des assistants
d'éducation bien évidemment il ya un
problème de suivi pédagogique je parle
de suivi pédagogique des élèves il faut
aujourd'hui se donner une nouvelle
ambition pour l'éducation nationale une
ambition qui ne laisse aucun élève sur
le bord du chemin et du coup pour ça il
faut y mettre les moyens c'est ce que
tous les acteurs nous dise enfin sur les
établissements spécialisés bon c'est
chaud une proposition qui vient qui
émane de la droite aujourd'hui force est
de constater qu'elles n'ont pas apporté
les effets escomptés et n'ont pas permis
de lutter contre la dégradation du
système scolaire des fois c'est même
plutôt le contraire donc il faut peut
être regarder ce que nous disent les
premiers concernés les acteurs et nous
nous ce que nous faisons et nous prônons
et nous prenons acte pour la campagne
présidentielle avec fabien roussel jean
pierre lecoq on arrive bientôt à la fin
de ce débat rappelle que les
républicains clairement votre position
sur
la responsabilité des uns et des autres
aujourd'hui l'éducation nationale il ya
une forme de laxisme est ce qu'elle a
son rôle à jouer comme le dit allez on
de deux fontaines c'est à l'éducation de
s'emparer de ce type de problème toute
façon la grande maison l'éducation
nationale ne peut pas rester insensible
de l'or cette situation et je voulais
aussi avant tout à exprimer à l'ensemble
des professeurs de france
ma très bon sens mais magnifique métier
qui est d'éduquer les jeunes
j'ajoute que les enseignants tous les
ans la france a fait choux a donné sous
verre ses écoles ses collages il sait où
tu es mobilisation extrême des
enseignants et mila je dois reconnaître
qu'effectivement
je pense qu'une fois dans l'avenir
réfléchir une réforme une réforme
salariale mais pour mieux veiller les
enseignants qui toutes les études elle
le pur ne sont pas suffisamment
rémunérés en france où une certaine
désaffection pour ce métier un très beau
métier il faut effectivement pour
retrouver les diamants recréer les
paiements et là j'ai
mon interlocuteur
recréation de postes qui ne sont plus en
assez grand nombre connaît par exemple
la matière de notamment d'affirmer à
scanner le désert total qui existent
actuellement français ce n'est pas qui
n'a pas été comblé qui est une un défaut
majeur le nous sommes en pleine crise
sanitaire et puis aussi vos crédits il
s'agit pas d'ostracisme il faut pas se
cacher les yeux et il faut une du monde
tout trouvé un moyen tout en maintenant
insistant les sybelles par le système
scolaire une formation des situations
familiales difficiles pour traiter ses
élèves violents qui existe et que
l'éducation nationale balade
actuellement d'un établissement à
l'autre sans trouver l'établissement de
solutions adaptées à leur situation
merci beaucoup jean pierre lecoq d'avoir
accepté l'invitation merci à léon de
fontaine d'avoir été avec nous également
et c'est la fin de cette émission